[Music]
hello everyone buenos vias como estas
migente oh no wait it's hola migente
that's how i say it
i am in the backyard right now because
we are about to take off
before taking off we're going on an
adventure with the big mood girls but
before taking off i had to check on my
plants
and give you guys an update on my
beautiful plantat
look at that i repotted them all they're
all inside their beautiful little
planters
pots and also by the way thank you so
much for all the advice in the comments
from the previous video
i know a lot of you guys were saying
that i could just keep these plants
in the nursery pots and then put them in
the nice decorative plants
or i could just buy a diamond cutter
piece to
drill holes in planters but
in the meantime though i'm pretty happy
with the selection i picked so these are
all the ones that i bought from amazon
and they've been really working out
pretty well for me i got
this little lady here she's kind of died
on me a little bit
i also bought some globes for some of
these plants like especially the thirsty
ones
like these guys are really really
thirsty but i recently
i recently like repotted this one and i
dried out all
the soil because this snake plant was
this one and this one which oh my god
don't even look at this one this poor
baby is like dying on me but then like
right after i
changed up the soil and i repotted it it
actually rained the very next day
so all of these plants got like double
watered and some of these guys are like
it's too much water
it's just not good for me look this
one's just like no i have too much water
so oh and i still need to buy a pot for
this one oh and then also i bought a
creeping fig
so or ivy fig ivy the idea for this one
is to hopefully
spread out here or spread out over here
but in the meantime it's looking like
this
and hopefully it'll stick to the wall
eventually but yeah the rest of these
guys
they got too much water especially the
snake plant like look at this one oh no
poor little baby it's just it's i don't
even know if this is gonna survive
honestly
i got a lot of these plants that are
meant to be house plants
because of the fact that this space gets
like almost zero light but
i don't really factor in when it rains
they're gonna get really really watered
and also that direct sunlight the little
bit of direct sunlight it does get
it's actually too much for some of my
plants so for example the croton that i
have
i moved it over here because it was
getting kind of sunburnt a little bit
and that's my guess is that it's getting
sunburned stay with my lily oh my
goodness my cali lily look at this
she's like no it's too much sun that's
my guess
i was also googling and they were saying
like these brown spots could be
soil problems what do you guys think i
don't know
she's i just moved her over here for the
meantime same with this
and 3m because it started getting yellow
spots on the flower
and then this leaf is like really really
light green so
yeah i ended up moving them here because
this is the spot where it gets the least
amount of sun same with this one and
then i bought
oh my god look at this one so this was
the
sensitive plant which is that really
cool plant that if you touch it it like
rolls in
and it ends up moving right when you
touch it and so when i repotted it
a lot of the plant just like came apart
when i was taking it out of the smaller
pot and that was before reading your
guys's comments where you were like oh
yeah you could just leave it there i
didn't know that so
i ended up repotting it and a lot of
these like the plant part of it it ended
up coming
loose so i was just like oh no i got to
make sure it's like
intact and so put it in this one and
then i saw it dying slowly on me
every single day so i'm like maybe it's
because it's outside so then i brought
it indoors
and i had it inside the house and i had
it by on like on top of the piano by the
window
which it's not happy dude there's
actually mold growing on in here
i don't know if you guys could see that
but there's mold in there now so
i pretty much kissed this one goodbye my
first
plant death so i bought two more plants
that are inside the house
so this one not what it's called already
but this one's like
all of instagram and tik tok like all
the plant
people have this one i'm like oh it's so
pretty and then at the nursery they
called it like
chinese money or something like that and
i was like oh casey
a piece of your culture could be in with
my plant stuff so this one's actually
doing pretty good
in my opinion it's been doing great i
took it out of the smaller pot that it
came in and i
have it in here i did have it right here
right by the piano
and just last night i was reading up
about this plant and they were like yeah
they don't like direct
light at all and there is moments in the
day where the sun is hitting that spot
so i started noticing some of the
leaves started turning really light just
like the ones outside so
i moved it right here in the meantime
the sun does not hit it directly here
but
actually i'm gonna put it just more over
here just to be safe while we're gone
for the weekend
and then the other plant that i have is
this little guy
and this one i haven't repotted yet but
look how cute it's so pretty
i love it this one's actually thriving
pretty well and it's in this windowsill
too but this windowsill right here
does not get any direct sunlight it does
get like you know residual
sunlight or whatever but no no direct
direct sunlight i'm actually thinking
about taking out that other dead plant
and putting this one in there and then
i'm gonna try what you guys were saying
which is
not taking it out of this little nursery
pot but you know what since it has holes
maybe i will maybe i'll just
look at other pots i don't know but
anyway that's my plant update and
you might be wondering but where are you
going or maybe you're not wondering
because maybe it's in the title somehow
but casey and i he's right there getting
ready
we are getting ready for jess
and nikki and steve and gina to come
pick us up because we're going to be
going to big bear
once in a while we'll rent out an airbnb
and then shoot a few videos for you guys
in a different location especially we
shoot our murder mystery episodes at
different locations
and um yeah and it's also just an excuse
for us to bond so it's really more like
a bonding trip that's why the guys are
coming because it's like oh you know the
last time we
did this was before thanksgiving and
that was
ooh let me microwave this
so gina texted me and she was like oh my
gosh i'm so hungry there's no time to
pick up food can i get food really quick
and i was like okay i'll heat it up for
you hello
you have to pee and raise your house you
did it's did now huh
hello come on in guys are you starving
i just put it in the thingy oh thank you
so much
oh i was just vlogging right now but my
plants you're doing your plants yeah you
had an extra three hours from the time
that i
know oh get up i didn't know yeah your
food's in the microwave
hey and i was just telling my vlog
that we're going to big
[Music]
bridges tonight
good morning we are now in the cabin oh
sorry but yeah this is our bedroom
look at this tall ceiling so we slept
here last night right
and our heads are literally like right
above
this wall thinking right here like the
ceiling the roof because we're
all the way in the very top floor
there's like ooh okay there's like three
floors
oh my gosh so there's like three floors
here and we're in the very very top
and it's cool because we have our own
bathroom but this freaking thing right
here
all last night we kept there's a tree
right behind this
what is the ceiling yeah the frame of
the ceiling yeah the a-frame of the
ceiling
there's a tree right outside there and
throughout the night there was like wind
blowing in
the tree like the branches kept brushing
up against it so i kept waking up with
like
like staring at the ceiling thinking
something was going to fall on me it was
freaking scary but he slept through it
i was tired yeah we're really exhausted
anyway right now we're heading
to the lake but first i'll show you the
rest of the cabin
here is le cabin hello everyone's all
ready to go
look how cool it's like this big old
a-frame cabin
and then that's the view this is kind of
scary
oh i got this okay this little baby
right here oh it's a puffy jacket
more of two pairs of pants two pairs oh
you missed my tourist style food
oh that's cute oh i love this this is so
cute
yeah you know what i'm gonna bring my
jeans i'm bringing my jeans you convince
me you look like christmas right now
with the red and green
oh yeah pretty self-play
it's not christmas anymore it's been
very open the holidays are always around
it's always a cheery cheery mood we
gotta check this
out look at all this there's some snow
on the balcony
and then here's le view pretty cool huh
pretty cool look at all that snow
wow and then you can see the lake way
over there
we got this freaking no not this tree
but this tree
this tree was bothering me all last
night
see how like the ceiling's going down oh
my god i should have brought a jacket
out here because it's cold
[Music]
we're on the lake now here's the
beautiful
lake and i also put the pants on
because nikki was right it's a good idea
to wear two pairs of pants
it's freaking cold i'm wearing my
sweater and this big old puffy
jacket but i wanted to talk about how
i'm
absolutely loving my new hiking shoes so
thank you guys for all your
recommendations on hiking shoes i went
with solomon
look at these babies these are super
freaking cute they look like they were
made specifically
just for me because the shoelaces are
like kind of teal
and it has really good grip i i bought
isaac
the exact same pair of shoes but for men
because now he's a
big old man just kidding he's not a man
yet but he is wearing men's
sizes now um but casey already has
his shoes what do you got baby got some
new balances
been uh wearing them for a while now
yeah you're the only one
out of our whole family that has had
good hiking shoes
true they they pay off too because
you're not worried about doing the whole
yeah like just slipping
oh my gosh that looks so real i got
scared yeah yeah like a good grip
like yeah now i can finally join that
family i think yours is better than mine
i
these are not as red like as yours yours
really dig
yours is way heavy dutier than mine are
yours kind of like waterproof-ish yeah
i think so mine has gorflex apparently
that's
a thing i don't know i don't even know
what it is
amazing yeah right that's what it says i
have no idea what you're talking about
i don't even know either you know like
technology out out
outerwear technology though that's what
you're paying for
exactly so now we're all set we got our
hiking shoes on point
i feel like right now we were just
coming down from the car and there was
like a lot of
like dirt kind of areas and i couldn't
immediately feel a huge difference
wearing these shoes compared to the
shoes i was wearing in the past
i was like oh my god you guys were right
i totally needed hiking shoes
totally came through oh it's kind of
chilly though look you look so pretty
[Music]
all right so now we're having lunch at
this indian restaurant and ooh
it's so bomb that garlic pond is amazing
but
steve here the legend the legend
he ordered his tiki masala level ten
hottest one they do so i have mild this
is what mild looks like
let us know steve i think i smell the
spices what is the legend
what's the legends verdict you'll see
yes
saga it's a spinach potato
oh butter wait what's that butter sweat
sweater sweat sweat what is it
what do we think delicious oh yeah
delicious very good not
one like spicy hint of nana
thank you
[Applause]
i lost my taste no i lost my smell but i
still cut my taste and then i fully
recovered because it was back in early
december
fully recovered everything tasted normal
three months later
a lot of food tastes like a latex club
almost everything i eat tastes like
that's so tragic but at least this she's
able to eat some some foods i can eat
that's good feel bad for her she loves
chicken
i know okay so that was that one cheese
that was
strongly like it is
[Music]
[Music]
but at least you're enjoying this right
this one's good yeah okay good and these
are okay
plain rice oh yeah then we also got
mango lassies
but then when casey tried it oh because
he recently got his mouth surgery so he
can't eat
he can't suck out of a straw so i fit i
fed it to him where is it
oh this one's here with the spoon i gave
him some of that
in his mouth i fed you like an old man i
gotta eat
my food's getting cold it's hot oh yeah
the spiciness yeah it's not
not killing me at all
all right so now we're back at the cabin
and we're about to do hot tub time
so it's me and it's so nice yes and then
we have that beautiful view
of the mountain and you can even see the
lake from here
oh really yeah oh sick guys they just
left right now because they're about to
make us some drinks
and before i jump in i was like oh let
me vlog a little bit
but now i'm gonna enjoy this hot tub
time
[Music]
you